je tenais à l'écart de la place publique
c'est un contemplatif ténébreux
bucolique refusant la quitter la rançon
de la gloire sur mon frein de lauriers
je leur mets comme un loir les gens de
bon conseil ont su me faire comprendre à
l'homme de la rue
j'avais des contacts et que sous peine
de voir dans un oubli complet devait
mettre au grand jour tous mes petits
secrets
andrée de de la renommée vous êtes bien
mal embouchées manquante à la pudeur et
la plus élémentaire
dois-je pour les besoins de la pause
publicitaire divulguer avec qui et dans
quelles positions plonge dans le stupre
et la fornication sur le publie des noms
combien de pénélope passeront illico
pour le fieffé [ __ ]
combien de bons amis tous meurent car on
de travers
combien je recevrai de coups de revolver
dont rêvent de la renommée vous êtes
bien mal embouchées à toute exhibition
ma nature est ivre souffrent d'une
modestie quasiment maladif
je ne fais voir mais hors gagne
procréateur à personne excepté mes femme
et mes docteurs
dois-je pour défrayer la chronique des
scandales battre le tambour avec mes
parties génitales
dois je les arborer plus ostensiblement
comme un enfant de choeur pantin saint
sacrement en perte de la renommée vous
êtes bien mal embouchées une femme du
monde et qui souvent me laisse fermer
quatre volupté dans ces quartiers de
noblesse m'assure noise m'en passer sur
son divan de soir des parasites du plus
bas étage qui soit sous prétexte de
bruit ce aux couleurs de réclame
ai-je le droit de tenir l'honneur de
cette dame en chantant sur les toits et
sur l'air des lampions
madame la marquise m'a foutu des
mortiers
peine de la renommée vous êtes bien mal
embouchées le ciel en soit loué
je vis en bonne entente avec le père
duval la calotte chantante lui le
catéchumène et moi les mêmes humaine qui
me laisse dire merde je lui laisse tir a
même un accord avec lui dois-je écrire
dans la presse qu'un soir je l' ai
surpris au genou de ma maîtresse
chantant la mélopée une voix qui susurre
dans lesquelles lui chercher des poux
dans la tension grand-père de la
renommée vous êtes bien mal embouchées
avec qui mentent aux bleus faut-il ans
que je couche pour faire parler un peu
la ds hausse en bouche aux tic une femme
célèbre une étoile une star tous
viennent prendre entre mes bras la place
de ma guitare pour exciter le peuple et
les folliculaires qu'est-ce qui veut me
prêter sa coupe populaire
qu'est-ce qui va mener cette paire in
naturally du site un petit peu
d'alpinisme sur son monde venus en perte
de la renommée vous êtes bien mal
embouchées saône rethel plus fort ces
divines tempête si comme tout un chacun
j'étais un peu taper si je me déhancher
comme une demoiselle et prenez tout à
coup des allures de gaz mais je ne sache
pas ça profite assez drôle de jouer le
jeu de l'amour en inversant les rôles ça
confère à leur gloire une ans les plus
values le crime pédérastique aujourd'hui
ne pètent plus grand père de la renommée
vous êtes bien mal embouchées après ce
tour d'horizon des mille et une recettes
qui vous battent à coup sûr les honneurs
des gazettes
j'aime mieux m'en tenir à ma première
façon et me gratter le ventre en
chantant des chansons si le public en
peu je les sors dare dare sinon ben page
les roms
dans ma guitare refusant de quitter la
rançon de la gloire sur montbrun de
lauriers je m'endors comme un loir on
libère de la renommée vous êtes bien mal
embouchées